the views and opinions expressed on this
program are those of the guests
appearing on the program and do not
necessarily reflect the views and
opinions of eight news now or next our
media group
finding light in the darkness is a very
american thing to do tonight on politics
now history made
the enormous american rescue plan is now
law what does that mean for you
and your family and your bank account
gun control the measures passed
on one side of congress and their future
moving forward
as democrats push changes to background
checks plus
restaurant relief the move starting
monday that local eateries are looking
forward to
and a move in carson city chefs are now
fighting against
from eight news now this is politics now
[Music]
thanks for joining us here for politics
now i'm david charns
this week marked a year of living with
the coronavirus pandemic
president biden announcing thursday he
is now directing all states tribes and
territories to make
all american adults eligible for the
coveted vaccine by may 1st
the president said his goal is to put
the nation on a path to getting closer
to normal by july 4th
there's a good chance you your families
and friends
will be able to get together in your
backyard or in your neighborhood
and have a cookout at a barbecue and
celebrate independence day
the president also celebrating his first
big
legislative victory signing into law
that 1.9
trillion dollar american rescue plan
which passed congress along party lines
so we're talking a lot of money in that
plan take a look we've broken it down
for you just
to show you how big it is more than 400
billion
in total for those direct checks of 1400
for most americans those are for people
making 75 000 or less
a combined 70 billion for coveted relief
and tracing
350 billion to local governments to pay
for essential services like our police
and nevada gets
4 billion of that with about a half
billion going to clark county and the
city of las vegas
and nearly a billion dollars going over
to ccsd
now let's turn to vaccines president
biden is more than three quarters of the
way to setting his goal
meeting that goal of seeing 100 million
coven 19 shots
in the first hundred days of office
natalie brand looks back at how the
federal government responded this year
and
the fight ahead the race to recovery has
turned to vaccinations
we're now on track to have enough
vaccine supply
for every adult in america by the end of
may
so far more than 90 million shots have
reached more than 17 percent of the u.s
population
from vaccines to testing to reopening
plans president biden is pushing
a national response strategy in contrast
to the trump administration's
state-driven approach a lot of control
happens at the state and local level
and that's appropriate because it allows
jurisdictions to tailor what's happening
the policies to their communities the
challenge is that when
every single state is having to make the
same set of decisions it makes sense to
take that up a level
and provide federal guidance and
leadership dr caitlin rivers an
epidemiologist at johns hopkins helped
work on reopening guidance last spring
and says a key lesson learned is the
critical importance of
clear public health messaging we just
never got that really crisp
continuous messaging that could help
people to navigate this really difficult
year
while president trump received criticism
for mixed messaging as well as
downplaying the threat of the virus
his administration earned praise for
helping fast track the development of
covid19 vaccines
it's called operation warp speed
that means big and it means fast the fda
has given emergency use authorization to
vaccines from
pfizer moderna and johnson and johnson
while the rollout has been rocky
fema has now helped launch mass
vaccination sites with an emphasis on
reaching vulnerable populations
and underserved communities the public
health crisis
also triggered an economic crisis
decimating businesses and leaving
millions
out of work demanding its own federal
response
last march president trump signed the
2.2 trillion dollar cares act
the largest of five emergency bills
congress passed in 2020
it included stimulus checks expanded
unemployment benefits and the paycheck
protection program to help
struggling businesses congress is now
poised to send president biden's 1.9
trillion dollar coronavirus relief plan
to his desk
president biden paused with the nation
last month to mark more than half a
million lives lost to the virus
with americans still anxious about a key
question
what does the new normal look like i
think masks will continue to be a staple
in households i think that we will all
be a little bit more mindful to keep our
distance from others but we will be able
to reincorporate
a lot of things that are important to us
health experts also stress the
importance of laying the groundwork
now for the best response to future
crises
natalie brand cbs news washington and
the biden administration announcing
plans to invest 250 million dollars in
an effort to encourage
coba 19 safety and vaccination among
underserved populations
in other news this week merrick garland
is our country's newest attorney general
the senate confirming the former chief
judge of the u.s court of appeals for
d.c in a 30-70 vote
speaking to colleagues on his first day
thursday garland
promised to keep the justice department
independent and free of political
influence
he called his arrival a homecoming
together we will show the american
people by word and deed
that the department of justice pursues
equal justice
and adheres to the rule of law thank you
garland reflecting back on the first
time he walked in for a job interview at
just 26
and then the years of service that
followed former president barack obama
nominated garland to the supreme court
in 2016 a position
which republicans blocked well the
political spotlight is returning here to
las vegas
vice president kamala harris will be in
town monday along with her husband
the second gentleman douglas emhoff we
don't have specific details on the trip
yet but we'll update you as soon as we
learn
more we recognize international women's
day this past monday and here in nevada
women
make up the majority of the legislature
one newly elected member is democratic
assemblywoman elaine marzola the
i-team's vanessa murphy talked with her
all the young women out there you know i
think it's really important to know that
nothing you know should stop you keep
moving forward
i think that women before us you know
open the doors for us
we are opening doors for the young women
behind us just you know don't give up
hard work and perseverance whether
you're married not married whether
you're young
older you know it doesn't matter just
know that nothing should stop you
and so you know hopefully i can you know
myself and all the women here in the
legislature
you know have had and will have a
positive
impact for women to come what do you
think has been the biggest
challenge so far as far as
being here or my life which part
as far as maybe the path to where you
are now
um
just you know doors don't open quite as
easily for women
we have to prove ourselves
two three four times harder
maybe than the man would right so that's
tough
um for me you add that i'm
an immigrant i didn't know the language
right so all those things add up
and you know it makes the road
a little harder and then being a single
mom it made it even harder
um but you know us women were tough
and we keep moving forward and that's
what we do
it's just i think it's just in us to
not to give up assemblywoman marzola
speaks of camaraderie
among nevada's women legislators and a
mutual trust
even between democrats and republicans
well the nevada state democratic party
has some brand new leadership
progressives affiliated with the local
chapter of the democratic socialists of
america
now in the top spot and as a result
staffers resigned this week
it's a story that's been in the national
spotlight all week
the state democratic party is one of the
strongest in the country
one reason former senator harry reid
but there has been longtime tension with
supporters of vermont senator bernie
sanders who are now declaring victory
clark county commissioner segerbloom ran
for the party chair but did lose to
judith whitmer
vanessa murphy spoke with the
commissioner
one side was in control for a long time
uh
there's another side that felt they've
been treated unfairly that other side is
now in control
um so that i'm hoping that they will
reach back out and we can
bridge this gap finally there's no point
in having two different sides in the
democratic party we're united we have a
democratic president democratic governor
democratic senator
so our goal should all be to focus on
those and not
fight internally but but you know it is
what it is
um i tried to to bridge that gap and
obviously
i was not successful but you can't give
up now we did reach out to the party for
an interview with judith whitmer and did
not receive a response in time for the
deadline
well it's been a year since governor
sisalek declared a state of emergency
right now republicans in carson city are
looking to clarify the law that
gives the man or woman who holds that
position that power
assembly bill 93 would require
legislative approval
if a state of emergency were to last
more than 15 days
one of the bill's sponsors says this is
a nonpartisan issue and is
nothing in response to anything governor
sislak has done
we actually place the governor in this
predicament
if you think about it because by the law
that we have
you know it's his job to jump in there
and put out emergency directives
well let's you know so we saw a problem
let's fix it it's unlikely though the
bill moves forward since democrats have
control of the legislature we're
learning more about a proposal to remove
racist school mascots and place names
across nevada assembly bill 88 would
require districts change
mascots that use names and logos
associated with discriminatory imagery
the western high school warriors for
instance would have to work with school
officials to change their name
democrat howard watts of las vegas says
this also applies
to 60 place names like lakes and
mountains
where we can get public feedback on
these things where we can learn about
the history
about why some people see them as
insensitive
and and come up with hopefully some
better options for some of these things
that
are really hurtful the assemblyman who
is a unlv grad himself says he wanted to
see the school retire the hay rebb
mascot which the school did do
in january he says unlv plans to keep
the rebels name a proposal in the
legislature to prohibit insurers from
discriminating based on the brady your
dog is moving forward
sb 103 passing at a committee on monday
supporters say some pet owners have to
choose between their dog and their home
especially
if insurers fees add up opponents say
certain breeds are more dangerous
it is already illegal in nevada for
cities to implement certain policies
based on breed
coming up the pandemic not kind to our
local restaurants the issues they're
facing and the increase in capacity
happening next week
welcome back to politics now
30 of restaurants here in nevada have
closed during the coronavirus pandemic
the ones that are open are capped at one
third capacity
but that goes up to 50 percent monday
and then in may it's up to local leaders
to decide if they want to go further
than that
john langler talked to a representative
from the nevada restaurant association
about how they're moving forward
what effort was made by individual
restaurants by the association by some
of the restaurant owners involved
with the with the board and so forth to
not only i guess to try and convince the
governor to convince
southern nevada health district for
example state health officials
to be less
strict with regards to capacity still
acknowledging the health issues
obviously but
how much of a push has there been up
until now to say
we need help you've got to give us
something here
sure it's been a constant struggle every
single day
uh we've been advocating for police
policy solutions to allow restaurants
to safely serve guests because that's
that's the number one thing for us it's
not just a matter of being open
it's a matter of making people you know
feel and actually be safe
making sure we're taking those safety
precautions sanitation practices
in addition to what we already do um
it's just another level of cleanliness
and this you know procedure that we've
been advocating
so that's kind of what we've come to the
governor as well as local policy
officials
um and kind of relaying you know the
needs of the restaurant industry and
saying
look we've been severely impacted here
um it's something that we need help with
so you're in carson city right now the
legislative session is underway
what are some measures what are some uh
laws that are being debated right now
some bills
whether they're dealing directly with
the pandemic or just broadly the
industry itself
that have your attention sure
already this session we've engaged on
ab-106 and that
like i mentioned before distributes
federal relief money to state grants and
that would be distributed to our small
businesses like our restaurants
so our association has been working with
the nevada treasurer's office to
publicize these grants
as well as kind of again relay the needs
of the restaurant industry um what our
operators really need at this time
so we've kind of been you know working
hand-in-hand with the treasurer's office
to make sure that those grants are
distributed properly
in addition we're seeing the issue of
eliminating natural gas and that's
reaching the state house now so now
there's
an effort to remove natural gas from
commercial residential buildings
and essentially that would affect
restaurants because that would um
limit their ability to use natural gas
and they would have to essentially
use electric uh stoves so that's
something that really
affects the way the method in which a
lot of our cooks
and our chefs you know what they do on a
daily basis so that's something that is
really really a big issue for us
as well as retrofitting natural gas
current natural gas
equipment to electric which is again
extremely costly
and it's really not a time to increase
other operational costs for our
operators um it's yet another thing that
they have to kind of potentially jump
through and so that's something that
we've been really vocal about up here
at carson city and trying to kind of you
know make sure that the
representation's there for restaurants
you mentioned a few moments ago that you
know the 70 percent of the restaurants
that are still around no one's really
happy
is there you say and also there's a
light at the end of the tunnel
what does the association and its
members
envision for sort of the next
six months in nevada restaurants in
terms of
capacity funding survival
safety etc is if there's a crystal ball
here
what are what are the hopes of the
association members of how this is going
to all play out
sure so if we're looking at the covid uh
plan
we're looking at march 15th which is
this coming monday
as an important day for our restaurant
operators because they'll be able to
operate at 50
capacity indoor which they haven't had
for quite
quite some time i should say um recently
they've been
uh they've been limited to 35
and then before that it was 25 um and
then it was just
you know um take out and curbside so
you know like i had mentioned before
more capacity is more of
an ability for them to make more money
uh that's something that's really
important to our operators so
we're anticipating that we're we're you
know looking forward to 50
we're of course looking forward to 100
and getting there in a safe manner
we want to of course make sure that
we're maintaining you know people feel
safe and
uncomfortable when they come into a
restaurant um it's definitely a balance
so you know i think i think predicting
anything
uh in this pandemic of this last year
shows us that we can't necessarily make
you know uh plans but but we hope to you
know
um soon be a 100 capacity very important
to our economy here
well there is lots more to come here on
politics now up next the push for
gun control the new measures in
washington that one local rep is pushing
coming up next
you're watching politics now house
democrats say the two gun control bills
they passed this week will make our
country safer
in nevada we certainly know about gun
violence we had the
highest number of people killed in an
incident in modern history
nevada democratic congresswoman dina
titus talking to us
earlier this week the bills face an
unclear future in the senate though
our washington correspondent alexandra
limon has those details
democrats are pushing for passage of two
bills to strengthen
background checks for gun sales if you
are a felon if you are a criminal
if you are deranged well by god you
shouldn't have access to a weapon
that's what this bill does it has the
support of about
90 percent of americans illinois
congresswoman sherry bustos says
one bill would close the so-called gun
show loophole
by making it illegal for unlicensed
persons to transfer firearms to someone
else without a background check
listen i'm a father of a five-year-old
is in school i care deeply
about gun violence republican
congressman richard hudson says
these bills are not the solution these
bills again would have
not stopped a single mass shooting but
democrats say the second bill which
would extend the background check period
from three to ten days
would give authorities more time to flag
people like the charleston church
shooter
nevada congresswoman dina titus says the
bills still respect the gun
rights of americans but that doesn't
mean that people who
shouldn't have guns can go out and use
them in our streets as weapons of war
republican senator marco rubio says he
doubts the bills will improve gun
violence
the people are going to follow the law
are criminals the people that are buying
guns in a back alley
if they pass in the house the bills
would still need to gain support from
every democrat
and 10 republicans to pass in the u.s
senate in washington
alexandra limon and more to come here on
politics now up next why a las vegas
judge is taking the state commission to
court
you're watching politics now
a las vegas judge has filed a complaint
in federal court accusing a state
commission
of trying to muzzle her free speech and
ruin her reputation justice of the piece
melanie tobiasen has been under
investigation by nevada's judicial
discipline commission for almost two
years that investigation was
instigated after the judge gave an
interview to the i-team where she
accused law enforcement agencies of
ignoring a local sex trafficking ring
now that ring allegedly recruited
teenage
girls including the judge's daughter an
investigator for the commission found
the judge had
done nothing wrong the jdc then hired a
second
investigator and later filed multiple
allegations
that could result in tobiason's removal
the criticisms they've gone after and
completely fabricated
and in fact if you take a look at the
complaint in this action
they've completely made things up uh
it's contrived
it's vindictive they've written their
documents as though their press releases
in an effort to avoid the fact that
they're not supposed to talk about these
things
uh through the stages that they've
instead released these
uh statements that are essentially press
releases and by the way
false ones uh to try and suppress her
and punish her for speaking
attorney mark cook filing a blistering
complaint in federal court alleging the
state commission
violated judge tobiason's constitutional
rights
cook says the two-year investigation has
eaten up nearly all
of its annual budget for investigations
well here's a look at what we're
watching this week as we told you
earlier vice president kamala harris
coming to las vegas monday to tout the
american rescue plan
we don't have any details about the trip
just yet but of course we'll keep you
posted
all week long all weekend long on eight
news now
as we learn more and we thank you for
watching politics now i'm david charns
you can stay up to date online inside
our free app and of course
watch us every saturday hope you have a
great week and we'll see you next week
[Music]
you